Volunteers in idlib are doing what they
can with what they have
cut off from the world and International
Rescue efforts
this man begs the International
Community to help with a breaking voice
some of those who responded to us
yesterday are dead today
the site is just one of many in a
war-torn country further flattened by
these earthquakes
this volunteer says there are around 500
families buried under this Rubble women
and children they don't know who is dead
and who is alive
blankets are used as body bags and this
small bundle carried out of the wreckage
tells the story of a tragic end to a
short life
but there are still Miracles at play
the newborn baby pulled out from under
collapse building still attached to her
mother now has a name the doctors have
called her Aya it alludes to the sign of
a miracle a quranic revelation straight
from God
the first few trucks carrying Aid to
Sarah finally made it through the bab
and HOA border point
but many say that it's too little too
late
all other Crossings are currently
excluded from the United Nations
cross-border agreement with the Assad
regime
this is a border crossing into Northwest
Syria only an hour away from Aleppo over
the last 11 years of war it seemed
Millions pass through into turkey
seeking refuge and now many syrians are
moving back that way into the country to
help with rescue efforts
anxious like these men here anxious to
make it through and help
he tells me he sees no reason why the
world isn't rushing in to support Syria
I ask about the sanctions and they say
they shouldn't be enforced on the people
he points in the direction of turkey and
then back to the Border they're still
finding survivors what about us he says
there's no State there's nothing
as they wait to get in a truck goes back
and forth taking the bodies of syrians
home to be buried and then back into
turkey to retrieve some more
Sky News killis turkey